okay so tonight I thought would be
interesting for a change to go over some
pawn structures maybe this will be
something that we do every month or
something maybe once a month we can we
can try to give this a go there's a
special request Arjun I thought Arjun
would be here he said Marathi bind
somebody else said okay maybe we can do
the French advance pawn structure I
think people are generally interested in
in different pawn structures so maybe
this can become a regular thing so if
there's something you guys want to see
just let me know what kind of con
structure should we cover okay but a
couple of people I just asked people
this week and a couple people said in
Roxy vines what's that all about so I do
want to talk about this position here
that we got on the board so we can go
ahead and throw it over there we we can
see from this position and I've chosen
to go from Roxy buying that comes out of
the accelerated dragon so there's what
really characterizes this pawn structure
as that white has already advanced his C
and E pawns so he's got a pawn on c4
knee four and you can tell at some point
the C pawn got traded for whites D pawn
and white took it back with something
probably a knight maybe a queen
but the pawns on c4 and E 4 is what
makes this of maroc C bind pawn
structure so things can be a little bit
different it doesn't have to be with
black fianchetto angus bishop it could
also be sort of a hedgehog it could come
out of all sorts of different Sicilians
it could be a con there's all sorts of
different ones and we'll notice that
there are some some subtle differences
and an opening structure as complex as
this we won't have time to cover
absolutely everything so we're going to
cover this I'll only mentioned that one
difference in a position like this so
we'll pretend black decided he's going
to post Bishop on e7 rather than on g7
one difference is that
well now white could try to load up on
the D file and get some pressure on the
deep
which is fine black should be able to
defend properly in those cases but we're
going to focus on this so the biggest
thing in this position I guess the the
most critical element in the position is
face white has more space and in a lot
of Sicilians
black can easily equalize if you can
play a move like d5 well enough
structure like this is going to be very
very hard for black to ever engineer
such a break especially when you've
already played g6 because to do this you
would have to play you know e 6 and then
D 5 and that does create a lot of
dark-squared weaknesses around the King
so particularly in the accelerated
dragon move order it's very unlikely the
black will ever play the move d5 and
white's plans really involve
constriction it's called maroc c bind
for a reason you want to prevent black
from doing all of his plans so I think
it does make sense to at first talk
about blacks plans in this position so
with black is looking for activity what
kind of pawn breaks does he have in a
position like this well for one thing he
can try to open up lines on the Queen
side and get someone play by it moves
like a 6 and B 5 this is probably the
most typical way for black to try to get
some counter play in a position like
this so I should do things to prevent it
a very common pawn structure that white
will achieve over on the Queen side is
pawns on B 3 and a 4 we'll have a knight
on c3 which can prevent you know moves
like this so this might be one of the
big battles that goes on in an opening
like this it's also possible but it is a
little bit risky for black to play a
move like f5 now most likely because
both people have moved their C pawns the
Kings are going to be castles on the
King side so almost every game is going
to see King side castling for both sides
in these types of positions so you can
see a move like f5 does open you know a
lot of diagonals towards the black King
so it is risky but it certainly is a
possible thing that might happen in a
position like this and as for white well
in addition to constricting
one of his major plans is a King side
attack you can imagine so I guess one
big thing too is what you can do with
this F pawn you can imagine moves like
f4 and if there's a bishop here on e6
which is pretty typical of this
structure I move like f5 might gain a
temple on the bishop and it also gives
you a possibility of opening lines by
taking on g6 at some moment and because
you have more space in a position where
you've done this you can imagine
rooks from any one of these files might
come up and over and be useful in an
attack although there was a game too and
I'm thinking about another plan
sometimes you can play f3 followed by h4
and this was those the game from the
Sinquefield Cup
when Fabiano was seven and no and he
played this way against Carlson Carlson
and he inter played this this way as
black and so he could have gone eight no
and you got a very good position very
comfortable edge with white what ended
up happening was Carlson played aged
five and after some recaptures so maybe
I can actually put this on the board I
guess I can do I guess I can do funny
stuff so this is sort of what happened
in that game but then he Castle kingside
which was kind of weird but you guys can
look up that game if you're interested I
was a very good the opening was a very
good example of how white can get an
advantage in this type of position so
with that being said and you guys have
any other questions about this pawn
structure do you yeah question
nope okay so with that being said we're
going to jump to our first game we'll
see a game from White's perspective a
game from blacks perspective take a look
here this would be our first game so
we're going to check this out from
White's perspective it's the game
Loran frosene a versus Robert Kempinski
was played in Bundesliga and let's go
ahead and see what happened so if we
arrived via a very unusual opening it
wasn't an e4 game it came out of a you
know this opening do you know this
opening Kings Indian yeah okay good job
um so yeah how can this possibly get to
our structure well backlight c5 and he
ended up taking here okay we'll put a
couple more moves on the board and now
we'll we'll pause for a second and think
about this position and we're not really
too worried about any of the theory here
it's not just openings explained but
there are a couple things to keep in
mind when you're playing with less space
as Black is here you want to trade le
some of the minor pieces because it's
really hard to maneuver when you don't
have any space your pieces are cramped
and if you need to go from one side to
the other it's going to be very
difficult when you have pieces
that are bumping into each other so
black for his part wants to exchange at
least some of the minor pieces to make
sure that he can always easily maneuver
around so he played a very typical move
in this position he took the night so
sometimes why even earlier plays a move
like 92 you can also play 93 just to
avoid this trade if y can keep all of
the pieces on the board especially early
on then he can very often just get a
great position where black can't even
move but in this game black decided to
take and in most openings that might
seem really strange you know you're
bringing your opponent's piece to the
center it seems very very good for white
and okay I mean why it's always slightly
better in these types of positions so
much so that even for a long time like
the 1950s and stuff they were like this
is a big mistake by black you can't play
this way then Roxy bind is just too good
well I mean it's it's good and if you
constrict all their plans but okay
really decent players are playing this
position as both sides so there's
basically two plans now for black he's
going to decide what he wants to do with
his bishop in the game we're going to
look at Bishop to e6 another very
possible continuation we'll see in the
next game is Bishop d7
to c6 with pressure on e4 personally
this would be my preference but you know
okay really good people do this and
there's also another maneuver that I
guess we should keep in mind for black
one thing that black often does is he
plays the move Knight to d7 which offers
a trade of the dark squared bishop and
he's thinking about playing moves like a
five-night to c5 and having a very good
night so and you might be thinking well
when you play the dragon for example you
never want to trade your dark squared
Bishop but in this opening is very often
black that does want to trade the dark
squared Bishop the move c4 does create
some dark squared weaknesses on the
queenside that perhaps you can exploit
and more than that if you just look at
in this guy in particular what is
adopting a strategy of putting lots of
funds on light squares and you know
sometimes he ends up putting basically
all of his pawns on light squares and
that Bishop can end up being silly so
one thing that you often want to try to
reach your dream endgame if you're
pulling this as black is a good night
versus a bad Bishop so if you can drop
this guy back and these guys get traded
and then he puts a knight here and
you're able to take it you might end up
in a position where you have this knight
that gets to live on c5 and he has this
bad bishop here on e2 so that's one of
the main themes in this opening so if
you're able to do that as black you've
probably at least equalized maybe you're
even better but white plays this move f4
which is not the most common move Queen
to d2 is more common but I quite like
this move because it stops black from
doing his most obvious plan because now
I guess will test the audience if Knight
to d7 what's what's White's move here
f5 just trapping the bishop okay so I
like this move f4 it's a prophylactic
move it's preventing black from doing
the maneuver that he wants to do so in
the game black played rook to c8 so he's
attacking the c4 pawn obviously he's
leaving his a7 pawn unguarded
so I defended it and now perhaps we we
might be able to get away with Bishop
takes a 7 looks pretty risky but uh
black decides to play Queen a5 so the
Queen is starting to come into those
dark squares and he protected as a pawn
so rook to c1 now a 6 and if you know
what Black's next move is which
hopefully it's obvious what is black
trying to do why did he play a6 b5
exactly so this is what black is trying
to do he wants to play a move like b5
but white decided to prevent it and
that's exactly how wide should play he
wants to be thinking about stopping all
of blacks counter play and then he'll
use a space and the activity of his
pieces later on in the later part of the
middle game so how did white stop black
from playing the move b5
I was played in 2010 and in this
position white played the move a four
you're thinking about it they don't want
to say it for a four okay um so we still
can't play Knight to d7 we would like to
so he played an interesting move here
King h8 so black is thinking well I
can't go back because then you play a5
and drop my bishop I can't really go
here because you take my knight and yeah
so he's like alright I got it
I'm gonna play Knight to g8 which
probably isn't the best plan so black
did play a little bit goofy in this game
but what's really important to kind of
watch and take note of in this game is
just how easily white spawns went like
this so I just pushed all of his pawns
and really over ran black so and it's
also funny too so he went to H a fine I
go to h1 you can tell these are two
professionals they put their kings all
the way in the corner yeah but what's
really funny to is do you know what the
best move is according to stockfish it's
really funny yeah what should black do
so stock fish didn't like either of
those King wolves but King g8 yeah best
move for black King GA and then white
doesn't have to repeat he can do
anything useful I think keyboard
computer wants to do for could be 1 or
something um so yeah right what is that
fish No so that means I mean just this
was kind of a mistake but like but he
went back okay so are we really going to
be able to to take advantage of this
hello welcome welcome
and so I guess white is thinking too I
mean he has to come up with some plan
what is he going to do is he going to
play on the kingside isn't going to play
on the queenside he decides what one
thing that I want to do is maybe I want
to put my knight on d5 and then maybe I
can think about pushing my queen side a
little bit but as we spoke about a
little bit earlier there's a lot of new
faces now which is good black is usually
quite happy to make this trade because
then if he can trade the bishop for the
night and these two people get traded
and black is stuck with this Knight
versus Bishop usually that's the endgame
black wants to achieve but really this
Knight should be like way over here but
he doesn't so he doesn't want to go to
d5 because that would let black trade
and again we have more space we don't
want to trade the pieces so what did
white play in this position was it you
want to take the bishop okay so this
seems like a very possible move did you
have a follow up after this okay and
then probably he'll have to play a move
like this and so I think this is very
good for white as well so this shouldn't
be too bad I think white is just waving
here because well I certainly don't mind
if you take me and then you bring me up
here with check so I guess he's thinking
well that that's not going away and
maybe I'll take your Bishop on the next
move I can take it whenever I want so he
did wait on that although that looks
also very good for your idea but he
wanted to play 95 but he needs to get
that Bishop out of the way yeah okay
Bishop g4 you want to trade why do you
want to trade them
well you can take care check first
but yeah you didn't probably don't want
to do all these traits so this actually
alleviated blacks position quite a lot I
just gotta get my knight back into the
game maybe you're still better there but
but again when you have more space like
this you really don't want to trade the
pieces too much yeah we might have five
here okay excellent move that's exactly
what was played so I got out of the way
and now Knight to d5 with a very strong
threat
let me how do I waste a move we just
waste a move here what's the threat
yeah there should be six in the cleanest
round
so pretty strong threat if let's see so
facing that threat he decided well he
could play queen d8 but in the game he
took on d4 which probably isn't the best
so this is kind of like what you wanted
to do except for now we get to do it
with tempo because bike voluntarily
brought our queen to the the center so
that's pretty good for us alright so we
played f6 and you can tell that this
sort of was a big success for white the
opening really went White's way he has a
great position and we're going to try to
see how do we win a position like this
because okay it's one thing to get such
an awesome position and then it's
another thing to to convert a position
like this and I would warn you the black
does have one plan and I mean in all
openings you want to think about what
your opponent's doing but especially in
an opening where your whole goal is to
prevent your opponent from doing what
they want to do you really want to think
every move about what your opponent is
doing so if you are black and you wanted
to improve your position can you find a
really bad piece when all your pieces
are really bad but can you find one
piece that you might be able to find a
really good square for and then we'll
see if we the knight yeah you just can't
find a good square and I mean so first
just look anywhere on the board you know
look at all 64 squares if you could
teleport if you could just magically go
to a square where would you want to go
where's the best safest square for that
night yeah II 5 so if you were black
you'd probably want to get your Knight
to e5 and so the next step is just how
do I get it there and so if you think
about it maybe I can maneuver my knight
to the e5 squared so this is one thing
that the black wants to do so at some
point white might want to consider a
move like Queen to e3 or you can play
what he played which is also really good
and if I remember right I think it's
this position the computer wanted to do
something that is not very human the
computer wanted to take here and then
I bring this rook up and over somewhere
and why I say it's not really human is
well this pawn is really really good
it's constricting all of blacks pieces
if you do end up taking I mean okay so
this this actually is a very good move
in this particular position you are
letting these pawns become a little bit
more mobile so that's one good thing for
from the black perspective but if
something like this works in this
particular position is just black does
seem really cramped as pieces are a
really long jammed in the back here so
something like this might work but from
a human perspective it seemed why my F
pawn five on my pond on f5 I'm never
going to move that it's just such a
strength
such a thorn in blacks position because
this guy can't move and this guy can
barely move but what he played here was
also really nice it was sort of a
tactical move and probably he's thinking
well at some point black actually does
have a plan it's not like I should just
keep wasting time you know just play
like nothing moves for a while and he's
going to suffer black actually does have
a plan he's going to provide to bring
his Knight to e5 so he decides to get
serious on the Queen side he does a very
good job so here you place the move b4
so it's sort of a tactic if you take
here the point is Knight to b6 though he
should maybe consider playing this way
too based on how he gets no counter play
in the actual game so giving up some
material might might be okay here
I mean it's not okay but something like
this okay obviously White's better cuz
he's up material but maybe you can you
can wriggle free in the game he decided
not to lose material okay also a good
choice and he brought his queen back to
d8 now our a pawn is attacked by the
bishop so he found a good tempo move
Knight to b6
so it's just sort of locating the black
pawns I protected my a for pawn I'm
attacking your rook I'm threatening to
win in exchange
so the rook moved and now would you guys
play here is void so again these are the
kinds of little decisions that you have
to to make in the game of chess that
often it's these little moves that are
sort of the hardest I don't think you
played I don't even think you played the
best move here came perfectly here
I think he just waited here I think you
did nothing what would you do okay yeah
hey five this is perfectly fine move I
assumed I would just go here and very is
very good for you I mean there's there's
no reason not to do this here did he
wait or did he play Queen III because if
I remember right you know I used to play
move like Queenie three preventing black
from doing his own plan but in the game
he just you waited okay now he's
attacking me a pawn so okay so now a5
this is very similar not he went here
okay so now I'll move like Queen III
preventing blacks plan but black wanted
to renew his plan so he had to defend
the h6 square showed it to somebody that
today and they wanted to go here it's
that's not the way to do it
King to g7 so now I can do my knight
maneuver
and he put his robe back so wide it has
wasted a lot of time sometimes you get
positions that are so good that black
absolutely can't move I mean here black
you know has a plan I mean nobody going
to get it here and then if your knight
gets there I mean still White's probably
better if you teleport there but at
least he has a plan sometimes you have a
position that's so good that you know
you you just can't move and white can do
nothing forever and ever and ever and
you should you should do nothing forever
never fifty moves later move upon and
then do nothing forever and then wait 50
moves and capture something and then
keep waiting so that does happen a lot
where it's just a white and then it's
it's so hard to play as black and black
you sometimes over presses or just tries
to break free you can't handle it
anymore these are pretty decent players
so that didn't happen what Rick see one
does have a point
I mean he is lining up on the same file
as an unprotected rook which will have
significance because it's letting white
possibly play a move like b5 that's
that's the point of his move and it's
not really easy to move your rook out of
the way
so he's like alright I'll just go
through with my maneuver and I do like
how white played on the the Queen side
now d5 so though bishop drop back
and his his plan here was was pretty
good now very often it's black that
actually gets lots of counter play on
the Queen side and when the Queen side
opens up it's really good for black but
here just based on the fact that his
pieces are so jammed up it's actually
what can make a use out of this this
activity by opening up the Queen side
which will be sort of a temporary thing
if Black gets all those pieces over
there and we trade off all the rooks
then you didn't do anything with your
advantage but here white actually can
open up the Queen side quite a bit and
and make use of the fact that his pieces
are a lot better coordinated and I like
the way that he did it he took on a six
all right so I take back
I played the move c5 and here black
blundered he played a move that looks
pretty good but unfortunately this is
the losing move so black must have been
thinking you're attacking my a6 pawn so
all defended so he played Bishop to b5
which unfortunately is the losing move
so we'll come back to that perhaps you
should just consider trading trading is
usually good when you're defending and
not a move like Bishop to b5 because
it'll be similar to the game but perhaps
he could try to go for some counter play
and something like this still is really
good for white but perhaps that was his
best bet but he played here now so here
you might want to pause your videos and
I want to think about it's it's a little
bit harder hopefully some people can
figure it out so I'm gonna give you guys
like a couple minutes here just to think
about how you would play as white and it
is sort of a tactical variation yeah you
got it you figured it out what do you
think it is
C takes D six okay so if you do this
immediately I suppose I have to go here
and you'll take back presumably probably
with us and then here which okay this is
probably good for you
I think you can even you have the right
idea but I think you can even do this a
little bit better
95 okay so here it is and yeah
95 okay I will go here that's what
happened in the game
yeah now you want to take on d6 okay
excellent
so here black decided to check Bishop's
a little in-between move here and now he
took back and I think it's very very
tempting here for the human maybe just
to take on a six and probably whites
winning after this but he actually
played a much stronger move you know
it's really tempting you know just take
free stuff which is good enough but he
played a very very powerful move here so
does anybody know what white played
Knight to c7 awesome and here black just
gave it up he resigned all I have to do
is draw one arrow and you'll realize
that this is really good for white um so
it doesn't matter what you do you're
going to end up losing material here
your Queens attacked so either you're
going to give up material now or you're
going to move your queen out of the way
then I'm going to fork you and take this
perhaps people in this room shouldn't
resign in this position but uh okay at
the Grand Master last level he realized
there is an exchange and I'm playing
present a so I I give it up you want to
come in now you won't even be the
highest rated player in the room you
don't even know it so okay so that was
this game and so it's a great example
for the white side of he just responds
just went all in black had less space he
moved his pieces backwards and he got
himself into a very big bind and what
did an excellent demonstration of how to
break through on the Queen side and you
know create a lot of problems for his
opponent I do want to try to get to this
next game because it's I didn't know if
we'd make this into a one or two part
series but I want to try to get this
done and I haven't read these
annotations yet so it's the third round
in the tournament this is Luka lenok
versus laQuan Liam
laQuan has played here before he's
played for the the Archbishop's and he's
played a couple tournaments here so very
nice guy
and he had the black pieces here and
this will be a demonstration of the
kinds of things that black should do in
this position so again it was another
very unusual way of reaching the maracas
si bind but uh okay here it is and it
analyzes Knight to g4 which is an
interesting line but okay that's let's
just get to it and in the last game we
saw Knight takes d4 in this position he
decided to play Bishop to d7 first so if
white launched he can play a move like
Knight - C - that's a very popular move
Queen to d2 is a very popular move in
this game he played rook to c1 which is
not as common but okay so now we hit
those four trades and we'll see black
does something different instead of
putting his bishop on e6 he has this
other idea of getting pressure on the e
pawn so white is forced to defend it and
this does make it easier remember in the
last game it was hard for black to do
his his favorite maneuver and this type
of position but here he's able to do it
okay Bishop to e3 and this is always a
big decision for white should you trade
or should you not trade and usually it's
about 50/50 what people end up doing in
these types of positions but not trading
is a very respectable idea because again
if we can trade off these guys is black
and you put your knight here and I take
it then I get a good night versus a bad
bishop situation which can happen and
will happen sort of in this game but in
this game Bishop e3 and black will
eventually come up with a sort of a
clever crafty way of trading those
bishops so can't wait here a 5 just
solidifying the c5 square for the knight
so the b4 can't come and kick your night
away
III okay very solid and now a very
typical maneuver that's very interesting
in this position was played by black
when I think first II went here okay now
a very interesting maneuver now in
general since black is hoping to go on
the queenside and break things open at
some point maybe I want to enter
engineer the move b5 into the position
well these rooks would probably be
better somewhere over here on the Queen
side but the Queen's in the way and
actually the Queen might end up being
really useful over on the Kings side
where possibly in some lines you know
you can play a move like this and try to
trade off trade off the bishops in such
a position maybe I'd also have to play
groups like this if I could get all
these moves in and trade the bishops
that's a very typical thing for black
but as it is you know our queens in the
way of our rook so he decided to play
Queen to b6 and his plan is I'm gonna
bring my rook over and drop my queen
back and then we can try for that plan
and I can try to trade the dark squared
bishop ii that's exactly what happened
Knight to b5 while he analyzes like all
sorts of mines here Knight to d5 gives
white nothing we'll just look at this
briefly and he analyzes this one line
alright equal okay he analyzes a whole
bunch of lines here but we're going to
not go through it but I mean Knight 55
looks like a very normal sensible move
but uh he decides to play a move like
Knight to d5
okay which does of course prevent my
queen from coming here and you'll notice
in this line that he gave after we take
and go here you really don't want to
double the pawns here that you know you
might be like a double pawns but it's
it's actually black that's now going to
get a lot of Queen side pressure so
something like this isn't that what
you're aiming to do so by putting his
knight there he does prevent Queen to b4
but obviously that's not the dream
square for the knight now as per the
plan now we're going to drop our Queen
back to d8 we saw that last game so they
did it again
King h1 what's that
yes yeah black slain King h8 except for
really he wants to get his King to h7 so
he's going to end up doing this because
he's going to do this and this that's
his plan which is a typical plan but
we'll see also in this game it was a he
played something slightly more unusual
and more beautiful so we'll take a look
at that alright so black has achieved
his basic plan he went back and now
you'll notice - it's kind of difficult
for white to ever get his Knight to d5
d5 is where the knight really wants to
be at some point and then if black ever
takes you know you'll be able to decide
how you want to transform the pawn
structure but as it is it's sort of
difficult so white kind of went through
a lengthy maneuver to try to get his
Knight back to d5 so we'll see what what
happens here so he didn't he wasn't
interested in trading that guy
so this is the start of a very funny
plan for white his plan Wow well let it
unfold because it's kind of interesting
h5 as per the plan he goes here so his
idea is I'm going to bring my Knight to
d5 that way
I might also go this way
but I'm gonna try to get that night back
to d5 so he got the rook out of the way
the bishop out of the way and now he's
going to do a knight maneuver okay
King age seven back goes the night and
okay so was at this point in the
tournament to both players there were
only two players with two points so it's
look they're round and so I guess they
both wanted to win so the pawn said okay
you're Knight went away I go back you
might expect well you know this clinic
is about 100 points lower rated maybe
he's just going to repeat you know and
who knows maybe look one would have done
something different but they were both
there to win you know they both wanted
to win and be the the sole leader of the
tournament so he says all right I'm
going to go through with my plan and
perhaps going to c3 was even better he
probably should have because they were
going to c3 this does get black one
extra option now ad now that you
interfered with this diagonal I can just
safely boot my rook here on h6 then he
analyzes like a that was another lines a
thousand loops deep okay but he says
both sides seem to have accomplished
what they wanted
Queen f2 and now I really like this move
by black so again you may want to pause
your videos here we'll see if the
audience would come up with what black
played there's probably more than one
good move but he played the prettiest
move which is important and it does have
to do with the fact that we are trying
to trade the dark squared bishop so he
found a very interesting way of going
about it the move that black ended up
playing in the game Queen h8 you don't
see that very often so it goes on this
very long diagonal and his immediate
idea is Queen f6 and
you know there's going to be some trades
going on here huh so very very
interesting idea Brooksie - all right
he's defending the second-ranked very
good Queen f6 and what happens is now
since that night has to move somewhere
he analyzes this he says here
threatening 95 yeah it's like he doesn't
weigh too much analysis that's awesome
okay we'll go through that later we
don't have the time so after Knight d5
we're going to see a transformation into
the kind of endgame that black is really
really looking for in this position so
now we get to trade lots of stuff we get
to take the Knights off the board and
there's a lot of ways that whites should
consider taking back you decided to take
with the piece perhaps better was here
but it relies on you seeing a really
awesome tactic and in this position
something like this this is his analysis
and he everything you do is equal on
each of with the rook and I think is it
this position in some position there's a
super tactic it could be this one yeah
so in this position there's a super
tactic can anybody see what black could
have played in the game he traded the
bishop switch and then he gets the kind
of endgame that he's looking for so in
the game he traded the bishops and he's
got the night versus the light squared
bishop and white has all his pawns on
the leg squares so black should be
slightly better it's the kind of thing
that you're hoping to achieve and so
black played the opening very well it
was big success for him but there's more
monster tactics to come so we don't
wanna get bogged down here you can pause
at home so you could have played this
very excellent move Knight takes e4
which seems crazy because I just take it
but now I can take this fish up so if
you take with your queen I'm going to
take on f1 so this actually ends up
being pretty good for black he says
looks very Josh to me so hey you want a
little bit of material so black has to
be a little bit better but opposite
colored bishops ropes he's like higher I
said wrong that's all of his analysis so
far not a dead drop this that's chess
but instead he went here so I don't know
if he saw that move maybe he saw that
movies like I am is probably a drop oh
and he says exactly what I said he said
as a rule if black manages to exchange
the dark squared bishop and give up the
light squared one for whites night in
the structure he is fine but here is an
example blacks tonight seems to be a bit
more active than whites bishop okay
right so this is exactly the kind of em
game that black is hoping to achieve all
right so he goes down he's going to try
to tie white down it's nice and now we
get to use our queen on that super long
diagonal um a lot of a lot of things we
could do here he goes back he's he
doesn't want to prevent a move like 'if
I've so the night retreat makes sense
I don't even play d5 and okay and he was
says he was hoping to provoke White's
next move which was to attack something
leaned to g5 he gives a question mark
exclaim and now okay we just need to
defend against that and so it seems like
perhaps black has miss played this
position but maybe he's even it's even
more cunning than white appreciates so
it appears like well you just blend it
upon and why don't we better so mom no
no no no and and here again I guess well
what's the class what you would do here
because if I remember right if I
remember it he played a really good move
here
or maybe he checked first really check
first okay he checked first and you you
pretty much have to play here let's
let's look at his King age 1 question
mark of course not
King h1 probably cuz Queen d1 and then
if your take really complicated when
blacks rooks are much stronger than
whites Queen so so that was possible
so of course not that so rook f2 but
this also I mean has a problem now
you're in this pin and all right Lex is
going to come up with a really really
powerful way to exploit that in the
future and you know a really good move
by black really good move sort of
confusing and probably he did not
consider this move I don't think white
was thinking about this move yeah rip to
c5 yeah right an excellent move and what
is white to do well there's there's only
one move here so this this seems like
very tempting right that looks it looks
good was actually a big blunder big
blunder cuz I don't have to take back
right away I can take care and you're in
trouble
because you know I'm taking on f2 with
Jack so this would be a big blender but
it's really tempting so I mean white is
a sort of a predicament so his only move
is actually to give up the Queen but you
know you're getting rooks and so when I
take back you get the rook and I mean
okay the computer when I looked at this
it's like zero zero zero but it's it
seems pretty obvious that it has to be
black that's better because White's all
tied down and black has the plan that he
went through with the game and Wow if
this font was a little bit bigger you
won't be able to read any of it because
it would be like off the page wrote a
lot of text here but he played a really
really good move and so here you
actually you may want to pause that at
home there's no way we have time to
think about it but there's a super
awesome tactical maneuver strategy and
tactics all together so if you want to
come up with what plan you would come up
with here is black if you're able to
come up with the plan that I look one
came up with them then a big congrats
because what he did here was spectacular
and even though the computer said zero
zero zero zero zero it's still like wow
once you see that plan you like what
black wins so we're gonna really give it
away
h4 we'll see oh and then he gives away
the reason so that's good to know you
guys know the reason so you better be
able to like tell me why you did that
but but we won't spoil it for them so my
memorize that you got it you'd write it
down and then you guys can you know look
really really smart so this is the
beginning of a very powerful
continuation you know if you you want to
know a little bit earlier you got to be
in the live audience it's the only way
so uh be for this not a very good move
but it seems like it makes sense because
he's trying to get his rook active so he
got that pawn out of the way it was he
analyzed it's like no they're bed
I can't show you that because that's the
answer to the real thing okay
so he played rock a5 now if your knight
looks away and is knight to move away
then you can play trip to d5 so the
computer was screaming just play e6 and
then 985 but uh he went for it right
away
and while it does allow white a little
bit more activity it doesn't last for
long because you're all tied up
so here but you're still pinned and this
is very very annoying and it doesn't
last too much longer so if you guys were
let's give away what would you guys play
here so the amazing plan again you can
pause if you want to figure it out
Knight to g3 we won't explain more than
that but okay so the obvious point is if
you take this I take here and you lose
okay you know how guys you can go back
and I can do whatever I want I don't
even have to do anything okay well it's
gonna be good I'm gonna take that rook
eventually maybe I won't take it now
I'll take it whenever I want but you're
you're still all tied down in Campbell
so you can't really take that night and
the game c5 was played temporarily
blocking the pin no big deal I'll just
kick your rook away and probably you
should just go back to d2 and defend
passively but he decided activity you
know I'm going to take on f7 check and
etc but he just took here and white took
here but now black is completely winning
souls king moved and white was in a
particularly greedy mood he decided to
go here let's see his line so his line
is h3 and then take this check okay
let's see where this is going
lots of checks take all your stuff and
push my pond and I win okay that's a
good line
ah we got a lot of a COPI of fancy push
the fun
yeah but Oh a choke here very greedy and
now black really capitalized in this
position played one more amazing move
and the game came to its conclusion so
who can find the move the black played
in this position so if you're just
walking in its it's black to move and
let's keep that door shut scary out
there have you got it yeah Knight to h1
yeah what a pretty final move and now
you're just gonna lose lots and lots of
material um we can even see what he says
the final move is nice exclam yeah white
suffers heavy material loss and
therefore he resigned with this
important win I took the lead and manage
to keep it till the end of the
tournament so yeah a very fantastic move
and it was a very excellent example of
the dream and game that black is trying
to get he got the good night versus the
bad Bishop and we saw that white was all
tied up
black got to do all of the maneuvers
that he wanted to do he played correctly
on the queenside so hopefully that gives
you guys a little bit of understanding
of the the maroc see find so if there is
another pawn structure you guys want to
check out just go ahead and let me know
and hit like share subscribe and I'll
see you guys next week
you